this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which hounds the
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's taking a look
at the world war ii era weaponry of
sniper elite five a franchise that he's
actually consulted on before right the
sram whatever the details uh it's really
nice to see this gun in the game and go
i hope that
if you're a fan of jonathan then make
sure to check out the series playlist in
the description of this video and if
there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below right let's check
out the weapons of sniper elite 5.
so this is a franchise that i've
actually worked on with the guys at
rebellion which is a great experience i
have to say not directly on this game on
the previous game and then
a bit of follow-up work effectively
between the two so there are i'm gonna
be looking out for stuff that i may have
influenced or
i may have missed
or has sort of crept in since one of the
big things i'm gonna have to talk about
is well weapon modifications so starting
here with the
silencer or suppressor on this 1903
springfield i have one here our only one
with a um period scope on it actually
different setup to what's in the game
there this is the m73b
type scope very very slim that i'm
pretty sure was modeled previously we've
got a different model here i don't
immediately recognize as ever answers in
in the comments but we have a fairly
limited selection of us sniping kit the
the texturing looks really nice in terms
of the
the sheen the shine the dings the
scrapes
uh the lighting all of that some nice
beauty shots that dave has recorded for
me there i was actually looking to see
if it was photography reference from
this very object but i don't think it
was i think they've got that from
somewhere else probably already had it
when they came to us
manipulations that was something that
rebellion were particularly interested
in when they came to us at the royal
armouries was what's a period correct
position we've looked up period manuals
for that
we did some reference for them and i
know they've got some from elsewhere as
well the very slick bolt manipulation
that carl's doing on the 1903 there with
finger and thumb that's exactly how it
was taught in the british army now he is
an american but voiced by canadian i
think but he is supposed to be soe so it
made sense to us he would follow british
drill to some extent with some artistic
license anyway suppressors so
yeah obviously not one on this they're
not really a thing we do have a
the enfield 303 with a maxim pattern
silencer and he did call it a silencer
on it so they were a thing so it's this
is one of these plausible things you
could have if someone was really into
their technology had all the connections
necessary together to get that tech and
make use of it however as far as i know
it was not done by snipers in the second
world war the design of the suppressors
i could be missing something here but i
i have this is the first one i've had a
good look at from this game and it's a
really funky shape the reason silences
are cylindrical typically some modern
ones have broken away from that but they
still have a large
cross-section you need volume for the
for the hot gases to expand into for the
silences to do its job this shape i
don't know it looks it's looks like some
other type of muzzle device more so than
a silencer there's not a great deal of
volume in there and of course the other
thing is which i know rebellion know
about is high pressure cartridges like
rifle cartridges yes only so there's
only so much you can do
to suppress those
now major feature of the sniper elite
games is
the well rod pistol now what rebellion
have depicted here as you can see from
this one that i'm waving around here
the actual nine mil mark one well rod is
significantly longer
than depicted in the game it's got the
chunkiness
correct the trigger guard that's not on
the original 32 caliber guns
most of the details are correct it's not
long enough now i raised this with
sniper e4 and they told me that due to
the interchangeable nature of the
sidearms not everyone's going to run
around with a with a well rod the way
the whole string system works
you can't take it over a certain length
so that's why this is a
bit of a hybrid design this
large diameter and lot and great overall
length is what makes this thing so very
quiet that also results in the front
sight being in a different relative
position on the barrel than the version
that's modeled in the game
however i do know they did make
improvements to the well rod so let's
see it in action
quick pause there just to say that the
the subsonic ammunition in this and the
game absolutely understands the basics
of sound suppression and that if you
want to eliminate one of the loudest
noises from a gun the supersonic crack
then you need sub sonic ammunition it
doesn't break the sound barrier and
doesn't give you that sonic crack they
built that into the game to give you
variety in your ammunition uh the design
they've chosen is distinctively
different than a normal round for
gameplay reasons or for visualization
reasons in the in the menu it's not the
case subsonic ammunition might be marked
as such with a with a colored tip or
something not usually it's usually just
the same brass color copper jacket or
whatever as whatever normal ammunition
you're using so this kind of green with
a green
separate jacket bit looks nice i'm not
aware of a precedent for that
right so uh manipulation of this is good
he's developed some sort of a
technique like this there's no set drill
for for how to operate this thing uh
with the bolt extended which comes a bit
too far out
it should go this far out it does have
the two locking lugs depicted which is a
detail that you wouldn't necessarily
expect them to pick up on but of course
they have been in here and looked at our
stuff so how it's operated is good sound
effects all great those shots um
not subsonic and
frankly it's very subjective different
sound systems
all of that but it sounds like it ought
to but i suppose i would say i've been
having helped on this
[Music]
[Applause]
right so we're getting some kills at
some pretty extreme ranges for a pistol
here now that last one 51 meters okay
carl is prone he's an expert marksman so
it's a kind of extreme range you know
i'd say for any hand any handgun in a
actual fighting context not that i've
done it myself probably about 50 meters
is your absolute effective maximum but
hey if you're effectively sniping with
the thing like he is very hard to say
i'm sure some of you have seen hiccup 45
dinging gongs at 400 yards with his
glock anything's possible with the right
amount of training skill and all of that
so i'm not going to comment on that too
far
so i've heard the difference now between
the subsonic and the normal ammunition
it's very hard to sort of quantify that
it's probably the difference between a
fresh well rod and a worn out well rod
it's still suppressing you know pretty
well but it's audibly louder and that's
kind of the difference we're hearing
here so another way to go would have
been to have had the wellrod as a
semi-perishable weapon and then through
the course of a long level like like
these the thing would wear out and get
louder and so you'd be in more danger of
being heard the more you used it should
encourage you to keep it in the reserve
now that's not something i thought of
when when i was working uh or advising
on this game it's a
another way to go but of course that
wouldn't fit with all of the other
weapons in the game you need systems
that apply across the board each weapon
with its own equivalent modifications
its own different ammunition types and
so on so if you if you excluded the well
rod from having subsonic ammo or
something that wouldn't really
[Applause]
the work gun is one of two that we have
the other one's missing the stock
thankfully um they must have looked at
the right one uh when they were here
so this is a an soe alternative to the
sten gun or at least that was the
intention as far as we know these did
not see actual service but it's
completely plausibly deniable for a game
like this as far as i'm concerned or i
wouldn't have mentioned it it's just
really nice to see it in the game it's
something different that fits the whole
setup you can very clearly see this open
receiver design and the bolt sliding
back and forth
it really is
special operations executives take on it
on a relatively cheap submachine gun but
they wanted something more compact on
the stem the folding stock now
carl's keeping on its back with the
stock uh unfolded the whole time i think
that probably is what you would do if
you were trying to carry two primary
weapons effectively like that the way it
folds is there's a latch
there and you pull out and fold the butt
plate you finagle it
that butt plate slips into there
and it shuts and in the thumbnail that's
what it looks like the like on thumbnail
indicator for the weapon is the stock
folded across the top so it's a top
folding stock sten gun magazine so they
didn't address the main issue of the
sten design but yeah that's that's the
well gun it's shorter stumpier more
compact but it is capability wise it's
no different than a stem
i always find it a little bit intriguing
to see
gameplay or playing myself where you
find that
squeezing off single shots with an
automatic weapon is quite effective in
the game to me that's an indicator of a
quote-unquote realistic game so those
shots they're single shots at at middle
distance they're having a good effect
that's what we would expect to see
accurate
semi-automatic shots and then only at
close range would you switch to
automatic at which point you'll be
firing from the hit which is something
i've always appreciated this series for
in terms of how it depicts hip fire as
being not massively accurate but
devastating at close range that's why
it's for the assault position what we
called it in britain commonwealth versus
uh deliberate aim from the shoulder and
you feel like you're using a bit of
skill to have it have an effect
[Music]
right so one of the one of the features
added here uh well subsonic ammunition
makes sense with in in tandem with
suppressors subsonic ammunition on its
own would still make a certain amount of
sense the ranges that a sniper is
engaging at by a hundred yards plus
eliminating that crack would go some way
toward concealing
where that shot came from this deserves
a bit of praise i think because this
this is um
classic case of compromise between nerdy
conversations the likes of me and
trying to make a game that actually is
fun to play most games simply you have a
silencer your bullets immediately lose
damage for absolutely no reason there's
no reason for bullets to automatically
lose damage unless they're being fired
out of an integrally suppressed design
that is bleeding off repellent gases and
dropping the
velocity and therefore the damage which
is where that semi-myth comes from so
rather than fall into that trap they
have come up with suppressors and
subsonic ammo and it's just that they're
letting you use that ammo on its own
without a suppressed weapon i think it's
an interesting thing for players to
experiment with to be honest
uh the cruel irony given the uh
emotional support stronger there of
showing me
an sdg-44 tricked out albeit not too
much um i understand that games require
customization now and those of us who
are commodity can simply ignore that and
lose out by not fitting them we've got a
muzzle break i think on this which is
not not a period thing as far as i'm
aware none of that certainly have that
but it looks period appropriate i i'm
much more accommodating of accessories
on on guns and games if they at least
look like the right period and the night
sight looks right technology wise it
looks too
compact though if you look at night
sights even as late as the early early
80s 70s early 80s they were gouge
absolutely immense
with a huge lamp to illuminate
it with invisible light effectively what
you're aiming at and then the tube to
actually pick that up and have a cross
hair and all of that so i guess this is
meant to be a sort of secret advancement
on the german vampire nightside so yeah
i get why it's on there um i can't fully
get on board with it
let's see how it works
now i we don't have well we don't have
any of these sort of first generation
night sights that we can power up but my
understanding and i've seen the odd bit
of footage this is far too sharp an
image for first generation night sight
they were kind of a green blur
and only really any good i wouldn't like
to say maybe 50 50 yards 50 meters or
something like that but the frustration
factor for a player of having to deal
with that you just wouldn't bother you'd
probably turn up the brightness on your
monitor
rather than use it so it has to be
attractive to the player to use
right this is this is where the weapon
customization chickens come home to
roost i think is
you're giving people tools
you're giving them options and so rather
than something like this which is a very
nice period luger pistol carbine with
the little glue
mark on the back there instead of that
you end up with a bit of a
frankenstein's monster with a luger
pistol with a somehow extended barrel
it's very hard to extend barrels by sort
of just attaching bits you could do this
but you wouldn't there is sort of a
tactical niche for a pistol type carbine
but i think in this case you'd be just
lugging around something that's a bit
too heavy and complicated for no real
reason when you'd either be drawing a
sidearm or using your sniper rifle but
is it this surprising what you can do
with a stock pistol
with a scope it's obviously another
scope that sort of you know 100 meters
i'm 200 meters you can lob shots in very
accurately with that so kind of makes
sense as a sniper's preferred backup
weapon if you'd like if you had
unlimited resources like cue department
from james bond which of course he sort
of does because he's got uh station nine
um soe so effectively
when you modify a gun in this game you
are
you are being station nine but in carl's
brain instead of backing blighty and
having to wait six months to a year to
get that product developed and in the
hands of an operative you're able to
just do it on the spot
[Applause]
right the sram this is the result of
rebellion coming back to us after our
work on sniper elite four
and asking and at the time they were
thinking dlc what have you got that's
really wacky but just about plausible
that's that's the secret isn't it with a
game like this could then could this
thing have existed in that theater at
that time and be in his hands and so i
could not resist
including this in my uh shortlist of
suggestions and although the dlc didn't
transpire the sram is now in sniper
elite five first ever appearance for
this very unusual rifle now it says in
the description text it says develop for
special ops by british soe this is
actually not
an soe design and it was designed by i
think these guys deserve some credit
although i don't have a single name
designer for this unfortunately but it
was developed by the check section and
this is what they came up with so it
wasn't for special operations type work
it was a conceptual alternative to the
self-loading rifle if that makes any
sense to you and it probably doesn't
because looking back it's a bit quick
but this whole pump cocking arrangement
where you press
the trigger that's not a trigger and you
pull back the pump
grip the the pistol grip like it's a
shotgun pump and it pulls the bolt down
a ramp
i'll explain that in a moment and then
you push forward to chamber around
that was all about trying not to disturb
your
your position and hold
as a sniper as an alternative to
semi-automatic fire now to us today that
sounds a bit bonkers but at the time
not you know not everyone was sure that
something like an m1 garand was the way
to go they commissioned
in 1944 um
20 prototypes only two were ever made
we've got this one i'm guessing carl has
left the other one in northern france
somewhere so as is not complete it's
missing the front scope ring for reasons
unknown uh we've got some difference
here um the rifle seems to have the very
fore end of a number four
so it's not a perfect replica of our
only surviving
srem they have taken the liberty of
making the front end basically that of
the number four bigger site protectors
wouldn't wouldn't for end all the way to
that point there and then the barrel
sort of floated within the woodwork like
a number four uh that must be a
deliberate deliberate design choice
maybe in this universe they have taken
this concept a little bit further well
they must have done it's out in the
field and they've gone with with that to
protect the
barrel i'm not sure whatever the details
uh it's really nice to see this gun in
the game and go i hope
the thompson who got to have a thompson
in a second world war game i think
everyone would mutiny me included if it
wasn't included now i'm pretty sure i
showed the guys from rebellion this
when they came to see us um on one
occasion this is an
soe
modified
silenced thompson gun
and i think is probably the
it's not necessarily the basis for the
suppressor mod here but it is a little
similar the the way the suppressor is
partially over the barrel is the case
here but the suppressor design is
completely different they've gone for
something much more angular and unusual
looking uh personally i'd have stuck
with that but that's that's just me yeah
what are you gonna do you replicate the
thompson's best you can and then you
give people the option to change it up
so now something that is immediately
kind of triggering my pedantry is the
drum mag because the drum bag for the
1921 and 1928 models does not fit the m1
and m1a1 because they don't have the
cutouts in the receiver to take drum so
that's
not right that said it wouldn't take a
super least superbly skilled gunsmith to
modify a thompson receiver to take a
drum so if that was a personal
preference hey it's possible we've also
got the finned barrel of the earlier
model thompson fitted here including the
out uh sort of the sort of an outrigger
too but uh the vertical grip the famous
gangster grip
fun fact british soldiers even today
call the vertical grips on their s80s
gangster grips which i think is
excellent so this is this is kind of
just a fun historical sidebar to what is
really just a heavily customized
game thompson but um this game handles
smgs really nicely so let's watch it
so this immediately makes me think of an
infamous old pepper and [ __ ] marketing
department mistake where they showed one
of their pistols is the usp with
cartridges in the magazine backwards
because some for sucker in the marketing
department had just put the rounds in
and you know arranged it or maybe it was
a photographer i don't know but that's
kind of a kind of infamous in in our
circles and we've ended up with
cartridges
in backwards and they are rejecting
backwards by a little bit too clearly a
very a very minor thing that can be
quite easily fixed and this is the
trouble when you're trying to be this
faithful to the reality of historical
weapons or any other aspects of history
stuff's going to slip through right now
now the iron sights on the thompson this
is the highly simplified pattern of
lyman's site where it's not protected
it's just the sticky outfit this pattern
where it's the it's a sheet of steel
that has the protectors formed from it
and then the site is lifted out of it
pierced and notched if anyone's thinking
why is the player not looking through
the round bit that's the sight why
they're looking over the top well
they're not that top notch
is the close quarter combat side on this
pattern of thompson so that's correct
kind of have the player use either of
them doesn't really matter but this is
actually a bit of correct detail
i mean clearly what what these guys try
to do when they move theater of
operations as it were is include new
weapons that are native to that well
that makes sense and as a main rifle for
carl we've got the rsc
1918 uh which is looking pretty good to
me uh except the sight and sight mount i
mean this the scope is the zf4 the
german stronger there scope among other
things i think the mount i think is
fictional now it makes sense though that
the main rifle for the main character
would have to be equippable with a scope
to my knowledge that was not the case
for the rsc 1917 or the shorter 1918.
so we've got some nice internal in terms
of the feed mechanism on the rsc so as
we pull down the magazine housing
it's just a
plunger that keeps it in place and you
can see there that they have in fact
modelled the interior
of that i'm always impressed by games
that go to the length of modelling
internal
[Applause]
parts thanks for watching guys those
were the guns of sniper elite five a
series i've played since the beginning
and i've been fortunate enough to
contribute to so very very nice to see
where it's got to in the present day if
you'd like to help us out at the royal
armouries as normal there will be a link
in the description um you can also check
out our various social media outlets
and our own youtube channel as well
which um has me on it quite a bit if you
like that sort of thing otherwise i'll
see you again next time
[Music]
you